>>Reto: Good afternoon and welcome to The
Friday App Clinic.
My name is Reto Meier, I'm joined today in
the studio by Adam.
>>Adam: Hello.
>>Reto: And our executive producer, Ian.
>>Ian: Hi, I'm Ian Ni-Lewis and I'm gigantic.
>>Reto: And today, we're going to take a look
at music playing apps.
These are all apps that you guys have nominated
in the moderator queue and we're going to
try to get through the top five or six, depending
on how many we can get
through in the next forty-five minutes.
So, let's have a look at the apps that we're
going to check out today.
So this is the list, or at least it was very
briefly and there it is again.
So we'll take a look at TuneWiki--ooh,
these are all backwards on my monitor so I'm
going to look at them over here.
We're going to look at
TuneWiki,XenoAmp, then we're going to check
out Spotify,UberHype, XenoAmp, PowerAmp, XenoAmp,
and Player Pro.
[laughter] So--
>>Adam: It seems like something was nominated
more than once on that moderator queue--
>>Reto: Absolutely.
There was a little bit of suspicious voting
patterns apparent on the moderator this week.
>>Ian: There's a massive amount of enthusiasm
for XenoAmp.
>>Reto: Absolutely, and I personally look
forward to having a very close look at XenoAmp.
Before we do, let's have a look at our top
tips for what every good music playing app
should have.
This is the music
player 'must haves.'
These are the things which we're really looking
for as fundamental to what we think makes
a
really good music playing experience.
So the first one is it must play music.
>>Ian: Now that one surprised me Reto.
That seems like a really really stiff piece
of advice there--
>>Reto: I know.
>>Ian: It might be difficult for many music
players to live up to that.
>>Reto: We try and set a low bar that we thing
most people can achieve and I realize that
this one might be pushing
that a little bit high, but we'll see.
We'll see.
I think most of the apps should, should possibly
be able to match
that.
>>Ian: We won't actually be able to tell though
because of 'The Man'.
>>Reto: That's right, "The Man" will not let
us play copyrighted music on air, so you'll
just have to take our word
for whether or not it's playing back.
>>Ian: Indeed.
>>Reto: And in fact, that's why we have Ian
here on camera, he is going to be singing
all of the music tracks as they
come through to his headsets in real time.
>>Ian: I will.
I hope you cued up a lot of Lady Gaga.
>>Reto: Absolutely.
Well, we did use your phone so whatever's
there is what you got.
>>Ian: Oh, wonderful.
>>Reto: Perfect.
So what else have we got on that list?
So we won't read through them all, we'll just
leave them up
there for you guys to check out but it's things
like--you know we're really looking for that
polished experience so
we're looking for things like the ability
to control playback over the lock screen,
through notifications.
Sensible
things like using audio focus, muting when
we disconnect headphones, all those sorts
of things.
We've actually gone
through and tested all of these apps for each
of these things so we will mention to you,
even if we don't necessarily
go through and try each piece for each app.
So you want to get started then?
>>Ian: Let's get started.
>>Reto: Perfect.
So we're going to start off with TuneWiki
which was by far and away the most popular
of the votes
and in fact had zero down votes, which some
would consider suspicious and I just think
it's just an indication of
people's enthusiasm for an awesome app.
>>Adam: Well, TuneWiki has been around on
Playstore before and on Android market for
quite some time.
>>Reto: Absolutely.
Yeah, it's a popular app.
So why don't we--let's fire it up the tablet
so we can get the nice
high resolution graphics and see what it looks
like.
>>Adam: All right.
>>Reto: So--the first thing that I think we
noticed when we started this up is that it
takes an age to load.
Transformer Prime is actually a pretty powerful
piece of hardware and still took like three
or four seconds.
[off screen: "Transformer Prime is actually
a pretty powerful piece of hardware--"}
>>Ian: I’m sorry guys.
Producer fail.
[laughter]
>>Reto: That was a little freaky.
>>Adam: We gave you the executive title too.
>>Reto: I think we might need to take that
back.
>>Ian: That's exactly where you went wrong.
[laughter]
>>Reto: Too much power.
Too Quickly.
>> Ian: You two say nothing.
>>Reto: Yeah.
>>Adam: Even the load time that we noticed
just now, I think that this was just a little
bit quicker than the first
launch was that we tried earlier this morning.
>>Reto: Should we see if we can bring up the
phone cam and we'll see how long it takes
on that one.
>>Ian: One second.
[pause]
>>Adam: So starting now?
>>Reto: Yeah.
Two, three, four--so again, that was probably
quicker than the very first time we loaded
up but that's
still a good sort of four second load to bring
the first graphics up.
>>Adam: Now that may have been influenced
by the advertising in the app as well in the
free version.
>>Reto: That's very possible so that's something
to keep in mind is that you really want that
initial load time to be
as quick as you can so that developers, I
should say users, don't feel like the app
is frozen.
>>Adam: Yeah, that's true.
>>Reto: That's sort of a killer move right
away.
So okay, let's have a bit of the navigation
so I think first place
you want to go is 'My Music" right?
So let's see how that works.
So we can see, in terms of a tablet layout,
this part hasn't been particularly
optimized.
We have that sort of telltale really wide
list view sort of effect.
You know which can be okay.
Can be a
little bit off-putting I think if you've got
lots of black screen space or white screen
real estate that can be a big
of a negative, but generally speaking, I think
it kind of works.
What do you--
>>Adam: That's true.
>>Reto: Yeah.
>>Adam: They have used the action bar, you
can tell visually that they've used a view
pager with pager title strip style
here.
So we have an instant indication that we swipe
left and right that we are going to get to
different content in
the application.
>>Reto: Very nice.
We've got the standard--standard looking action
bar.
It doesn't look quite right, is it slightly
higher than it should be?
>>Adam: Well, it looks like, on the tablet,
it's about the right size, but on the phone
it seems to be slightly
oversized.
>>Reto: Hmm.
Okay.
Yeah, I'm looking at them both in front of
me so that's interesting.
All right.
let's play a song, let's uh--
>>Ian: Actually, would you mind putting the
phone up there Daniel so we can see what Adam's
talking about.
>>Daniel: Sure.
>>Ian: While Daniel's doing that I just want
to remind everybody that I'm watching the
live stream right now on
YouTube, and so if you have any questions
that you want to pass along to Reto and Adam
go ahead and type them in
there--that's where we're watching, not on
the Google Plus stream 'cause I can only do
one thing at a time.
[soft
laughter in background] All right, go ahead
guys.
>>Adam: All right, thanks man.
>>Reto: We definitely should consider--we
should have kept something in reserve.
Executive producer should have been
the credit that you get when you CAN do two
things at once.
>>Ian: Hmm.
>>Reto: But in the meantime-- so let's have
a look--you reckon this is slightly too tall?
Can you talk us through--
how can you tell or are you just like Roman
and able to spot two pixel differences just
through raw eye?
>>Adam: It's mostly that.
>>Reto: Nice.
>>Adam: In this case, it's mostly a matter
of sort of visually measuring against some
of the other elements on the
screen but the real tell-tell thing in this
UI in particular is if you check the size
of the touch highlight that
sits there, you notice that the button itself
of the touch target itself is slightly smaller
than the full bar.
Now, that's not a bad thing on its own, but
it does sort of reveal the difference here.
>>Reto: Yeah.
Okay.
So that's nice, I mean while we're looking
at the action bar as well, I'd point out that
you've kind of got settings menu is here as
well, which again isn't a standard preferences
screen--you can tell from
these right carets or chevrons which are non-standard
so it's obviously custom.
It's looks relatively standard so
it's not too bad but it would be kind of nice--there's
no real reason not to go with the standard
on the preferences
screen here so would be kind of nice if you
guys did.
>>Adam: If you go back--
>>Ian: Can you touch one of those, I'm really
curious why people use the right caret.
I have my own theories but--
>>Adam: Usually it's just to indicate that
there's another screen underneath it that's
going to take you someplace
different.
>>Ian: [sharp intake of breath] I think that's
true, but why in particular the right caret
because the action
for going to another screen has nothing to
do with anything to the right of what you
see right--
>>Reto: Hmm.
That's true.
>>Ian:-- so I guess what I'm implying is that
maybe that's a carryover from you know some
other type of system where
the animation is different or---
>>Reto: Yeah, it feels that way, like as though
maybe the developers have used a different
operating system which
perhaps when you hit right everything slides
from left to right so that you can sort of--
>>Adam: You mean an operating system like
Gingerbread?
>>Reto: Possibly.
[laughs] Possibly a different operating system
like Gingerbread.
>>Adam: So one of the other elements here
as well is--the design guide I believe explicitly
calls out the case of
settings as something that shouldn't be either
frequent, important or typical--so realistically
that should be in an
overflow--
>>Reto: Exactly.
>>Adam:--but it's entirely understandable
in a case like this where that's the only
option that would be in the
overflow there's sort of a simple judgment
call to be made there.
>>Reto: Yeah.
I agree.
I think in this case though I mean what you've
got here if nothing else is just taking up
more screen real estate.
It's something else the user has to look at
and understand.
Like you see a cog and you're
like "What does the cog mean?"
Which means you need to press it to find out,
and I think just having that overflow
menu is kind of where users are expecting
things like settings to be so it makes it
sort of cognitively easy to
understand what you're supposed to do because--and
again this is something I tend to go on a
bit at length but it's
creating that magical experience where as
soon as you launch the app, you should be
doing whatever it is the app is
designed to do straightaway.
So you shouldn't have to spend time exploring
the app and figuring out how it all works
in order to understand it's value.
Like people are going to install this, start
using it, and the less they have to
think about how things work, it's kind of
the more of a magical experience it is for
those people.
>>Adam: That's definitely true, but what you
need to watch out for as well--and I think
what developers look at when they
make decisions such as this-- is what do you
do--a lot of developers will count clicks--
>>Reto: Hmm.
>>Adam:-- in terms of how deep an action is
or how complex the process for getting to
a particular action is.
And I
think in this case the decision was made "Okay,
one click is better than two."
>>Reto: Mmm.
>>Adam: So--but that's not always the only
metric you should use when deciding on UI
elements such as this.
>>Reto: Yeah, I think what you were saying
earlier is kind of the key there is--it's--you
want to make it really
quick and easy to do the things that are most
important for your app.
Anything that you don't want people to do
all
the time, can afford to live further away.
In fact, we had this discussion when we were
looking at this app earlier
today around the "My Profile" button.
>>Adam: We did.
>>Ian: Can I cut in for just a second?
>>Reto: You can.
>>Ian: Umm, several people are mentioning
that Adam's far too quiet.
>>Adam: Oh, am I?
>>Ian: Yeah, so you might want to--
>>Adam: Is that just because I keep turning
my head when I'm talking?
>>Ian: That--possibly.
Um, it might also be the mic volume and also
just project Adam, just project.
I think you've
still got half a shot of whiskey there you
might want to down it.
[laughter]
>>Adam: There's none here.
Okay.
>>Reto: All right, now we have loud Adam hopefully.
>>Adam: I think we're good to go.
>>Reto: Maybe I should just be more quiet
and we can just adjust all the gain up.
>>Ian: I think that would be a terrible idea,
I think you guys should be like our boss when
we're in a teleconference
[laughter] and he starts like shouting at
the people across the room.
I think that's how you guys
should think of yourself right now.
>>Reto: All Right.
We can do that.
>>Ian: Project!
>>Adam: Shout at the users.
>>Reto: Shout at the users--
>>Ian: Pretty much.
>>Reto:--and the developers.
Wow.
There's so many of us on screen now.
[laughter]
Okay.
Like we were saying we had this exact discussion
about 'My Profile' and---
>>Adam: Do we want to look at that?
I think that we had some other elements or
do we want to move on straight to
"does it play music?"
>>Reto: Let's look at this first and then
we'll go on to--"will it play music?"
next because I'm sure we need to keep
something there as a suspense for our users,
does it play music?
>>Adam: This is true.
>>Reto: So my opinion with 'My Profile' seemed
like the kind of thing that should go on the
overflow menu.
It's
like, how often are you going to change it?
With any kind of social networking, you do
your profile once and you're
kind of done.
You disagree.
>>Adam: Well, I--
>>Reto: And at the time we hadn't logged in
so...
>>Adam: That's true.
>>Reto: So, it's hard to say.
>>Adam: Well I thought there was especially
a defense for an app like this that aims to
make your music a bit more
social, a bit more of a connected experience.
So I thought that that decision reflected
[whoosh of bottle opening]
on where they wanted this app to go.
>>Reto: So basically you're saying if the
whole point is to make it more of a social
song experience then it sort of
makes sense to have that social media stuff
front and center.
>>Adam: Right.
>>Reto: So in fact, if we go in, we can see
that it really is, it's more than just who
are you and what's your
current status, you can add personal messages,
list your top songs, your top artists--so
it's really stuff which is
going to change--
>>Adam: Right.
>>Reto:-- on almost a daily basis, right?
So I guess in summary we're saying, yeah,
fair enough.
And they've got all
of this soc--basically this 'My Profile" is
just a way into the more social experience
of the app.
Though I have to
say that the styling of this section could
do with something of a revamp.
Feels a little old.
Feels a little you know static-y , absolute
lay out-y almost.
>>Adam: Well it is using the Holo style buttons
and such, but I think that it's --it sort
of forms this grid of
gray--
>>Reto: Hmm.
>>Adam: That's a little bit difficult visually
get away from.
>>Reto: Yeah.
>>Adam: I think that some icons--er--some
other splashes of color on this screen--
>>Reto: Mmm.
>>Adam:--could really liven things up a little
bit.
>>Reto:This is the thing, I've spent entirely
too much of my life, before joining Android,
writing applications in
Cshell.net format for financial organizations
so I've seen far too many of these screens
which are just ranges of
gray buttons on lighter gray backgrounds so--maybe
it's just a hind brain thing that just sets
me off but--
>>Adam: That's entirely fair.
>>Reto: Yeah.
I'd like it to look a little bit prettier,
particularly considering that the rest of
the app is styled.
Like, you've obviously got a designer here
creating these, you know, very strong visual
graphics and so it'd be great
to see that sort of promoted throughout the
entire app.
Do we want to have a look to see if it plays
any music?
[pause]
>>Adam: I don't know that sounds a little
bit daring.
>>Reto: I know, but at some point we're going
to have to run this apps really through their
paces.
>>Adam: Let's give it a shot.
>>Reto: So let's take a look.
>>Adam: So let's take a look at our music.
So we jump into what's at this point a fairly
standard list of tracks.
We
noticed that again the view pager title indicator
gives us a simple indication of some of the
other functions that
exist just off screen.
>>Reto: Mmm.
>>Adam: We have a streaming radio built in,
via SHOUTcast that's [unintelligible]
>>Reto: This is really nice.
And this is something that me and Ian actually
called out for podcast players that we
would like to see a media player which has
both live--you know, our own audio we can
listen to and also having live
streaming radio type functionality, so this
is a big plus for me.
It kind of takes account of two different
apps in
one place.
>>Adam: Absolutely.
>>Reto: I have to say though, I found it a
little bit hidden, because if we go back to
the main menu it's 'My Music'
right?
So I'm expecting this is where I go to listen
to things that are already in my library.
And it's not until--
>>Adam: It gives it a little bit of this 'My
Computer'--
>>Reto: Yeah.
>>Adam: --nineties feel to it in that case.
>>Reto: Exactly.
And really what we're just saying is Music.
So it would be much nicer there and being
able to have
the streaming stuff more readily available
and readily apparent I think would be a real
plus.
>>Adam: Right.
So, next we get into some of the things on
the library screen here.
The 'shuffle all', 'show all songs' and 'show
all
albums' elements here are really tiny touch
targets.
>>Reto: Mmm.
>>Adam: I mean, these things are probably
under 40 DP tall.
Generally we try and go at least 48 in both
dimensions to
try and get a nice, happy touch target, so
it's easy to hit.
>>Reto: Absolutely.
>>Adam: So it would be nice if those were
a little bit bigger.
I definitely can see wanting to break it up
and still
see a little bit more of the content and still
separate it out from the songs themselves
a little bit--
>>Reto: Yeah.
>>Adam: But I think that the icons and some
other styling could be used to help with that
as well.
>>Reto: Absolutely.
I mean, there's a few options you've got here.
Personally this as sort of three touch targets
all a bit bigger with sort of icons with text
underneath or something along those lines.
>>Adam: That's an option.
>>Reto: But something certainly easier to
touch.
Every time someone tries to touch something
and feels like they're
going to miss or touches the wrong thing,
it's kind of a bad experience for your users
so you want to, you know,
avoid that if at all possible.
>>Adam: Right.
>>Reto: All right.
Lyle Lovett.
Let's have a look.
Songs and Albums.
So again we go through here, we've got the
album
covers at this points along with the names
and everything else.
>>Adam: That's right.
>>Reto: We've got touch targets on the end--see
this is--
>>Adam: So this was something that stood out
while we were testing this as well.
>>Reto: Mmm.
>>Adam: We have the secondary touch targets
along this list items, very similar to what
Google Play Music has, but
you'll notice that these don't actually have
any sort of a press highlight that's readily
visible or if it does, it's
very very subtle.
Again, that's just one of those small polish
type of elements, but it is responsive.
I haven't
actually managed to miss that touch target,
yet.
>>Reto: It looks like it's the right size,
you just don't know that you're touching it.
>>Adam: Right.
It would be nice to see a little bit more
of a visual confirmation as well.
>>Reto: It's also worth noting as well, it's
almost a contradiction in styles here.
Where in the config menu, we've
got the right facing caret and here we've
got the sort of bottom right corner caret
indicating a drop down menu.
I
think it's probably clear to most users how
those are different but it kind of highlights
that in Android clicking on
something means navigate to or perform that
action and anything else you've got on the
right is sort of an in place
context menu if you will.
>>Adam: That's true.
So should we actually try and play some music?
>>Reto: Let's try, yeah.
Make sure that the volume control works.
So this is good, we're actually adjusting
the
volume control of the media stream rather
than the ringer.
Even though we're not playing music so that's
important.
I'm going to mute that so "The Man" doesn't
get us.
>>Adam: Well it's always great to make sure
that you can adjust that volume before you
actually start playing.
>>Reto: Exactly.
>>Adam: No one wants to get blasted by music
the second they hit the play button.
>>Reto: Exactly right.
Or miss the start if the audio is too low.
>>Adam: Also true.
>>Reto: Just as bad.
Okay.
Which title which looks, you know, kind of
like an innuendo should we go with?
'Lyle Lovett and His Large--' or 'It's Not
Big It's Large ?'
Let's go with '--and His Large'
>>Adam: Band.
>>Reto: BAND!
Of course, that's what you were all thinking.
Okay, so again we've navigate down through
the albums, and now we go through to the song,
and it all works.
So it's
instrumental so you can see here kind of one
of the key selling points of TuneWiki--is
that it will allow you to
view the lyrics of songs if they happen to
be in the library.
>>Adam: And not only that, but it follows
a very karaoke scrolling mechanism for each
line in the song so as the song
plays, it scrolls forward and shows the current
lyrics.
>>Reto: Let's see if we can find one.
Uh--let's see.
We might have more likelihood of having lyrics
for--so you can
see that the lyrics are loading up, it gets
uh--that's been pulled--
>>Adam: At the publisher's request--
>>Reto: You can see that as it's sort of pulling
down making that request you got a little
flashy in that box it
feels like you could probably do all of that
stuff like do all the caching, all the checking,
do all that offline
before you start updating the UI so that you
kind of get away from that, you know, things
flashing.
>>Adam: That's true, especially when you have
a local music library that's not going to
change terribly often, or
when it does, you know that you're re-indexing
and that you have some new content.
>>Reto: Absolutely.
Here you can see exactly what we're talking
about.
You’ll slowly eventually start to see the
lyrics start to move as the song continues
to play.
Ian, did you want to sing along for us?
>>Ian: No, I don't sing The Clash.
>>Reto: Ah.
You should have checked on this beforehand.
Otherwise, it works pretty well.
One thing that you may want to be a little
bit cautious of, and I think it's okay in
this app but just a general piece of advice,
you've got some pretty small touch targets
along the bottom to control
the music playback right next to the ad.
Now there are some ad policies around making
sure that you don't have action targets where
they could accidentally
result in an ad click.
I think the general way that music players
are constructed is there is an expectation
that
that's where the playback controls will be--
>>Adam: That's true.
>>Reto: But, you know, it's definitely something
to be cautious of here.
Particularly because these are all a little
bit small, particularly when you get to things
like random and repeat, you know, the icons
themselves are quite
little and immediately next to the ad.
>>Adam: Right and keep in mind, it doesn't
necessarily matter how large the icon is.
It matters how large the touch
target itself is.
How easy is it to really miss.
>>Reto: Mmm.
>>Adam: So you can see as we go into press
this--once again this is actually fairly small
but it is separated out
from the ad as well so I think that in terms
of being too close to the ad, that's not too
much of a problem.
Oh, my
head's in the frame.
[Reto laughs]
In terms of being too close to the ad, that's
not much of a problem but it might be a little
bit easy to miss those
depending on--
>>Reto: Yeah.
>>Adam: Depending on how you're using it.
>>Reto: And how big your fingers are.
>>Adam: All but true.
>>Reto: So we can scroll along here so while
we're listening to a particular artist you
can see we've got more
information about the group, there's this
whole community aspect that we talked about
before, and so you can see
other people who have shared this music or
are fans of The Clash.
So this is where it gets a little bit interesting.
We discussed this a little beforehand but
basically all of the
sharing options that you have within the app
are tightly bound to Facebook and Twitter.
Now they're probably two of
the most popular mechanisms for social sharing
but then, they're not the only ones and as
it happens, on this phone
we have neither of these apps installed because
we want to share things other ways.
And so, you know, you've got
basically this app which you want people to
promote for you, and I can't promote them
on G-plus, I can't promote them
via email or anything else because I can only
use these two things.
So we'd really like to see you sort of using
a
more standard share intent or send intent
so that any app that I've got on the app that
I use for sharing can be used
to get this information out there.
>>Adam: Right and just because you use this--just
because we recommend the standard android
sharing doesn't mean that
you can't do some deeper integration with
some of these other specific SDK's but in
the case of this app, if you go
to the specific share action that's here,
we get something that's once again very very
tailored to these two
networks such that it's not actually possible
to share any other way.
>>Reto: Mmm.
>>Adam: Either that or we missed that functionality
somewhere buried---
>>Reto: And if we missed it, it's kind of
too buried and that's kind of the key, right?
You want to make it
something which people can get to.
So you go through the overflow menu, that's
all great so now--actually I'm gonna
scroll back to this song as it continues to
play.
>>Adam: So I just want to point out some of
the other features that they include in the
overflow menu that are kind
of interesting.
>>Reto: Hmm.
>>Adam: They do have some really convenient
things like 'keep screen on' and again this
could be useful for the
karaoke style lyrics--
>>Reto: Absolutely.
>>Adam: You’ve got 'set as ringtone' which
is always convenient.
You've got 'start a sleep timer' in case you've
got
a long playlist that you want to shut off
after a while--
>>Reto: Nice.
>>Adam: It's a fairly feature full app.
>>Reto: Absolutely and I think that's something
that we definitely decided when we were looking
at this was that as
far as music playing apps go, this has kind
of everything you could ask for and most of
what we're pointing out here
is relatively minor UI tweaks sort of things
you can do to make the app a little bit cleaner,
a little bit more
polished but I think, overall, we're really
really happy with this.
I think this is a great example.
So let's check out a couple more things.
So we're playing audio at the moment, if we
turn on turn off--try that
again--so unfortunately no lock screen controls
now this kind of sucks because for me--a big
use case for me is while
I'm driving so I want to be able to get to
those controls really quickly and easily without
having to look at my
phone at all like, I only, of course, will
be doing this while I'm stopped but even still,
I don't want to play with
my phone and unlock it.
I have a PIN unlock and all those sorts of
things.
Makes it more tiresome, I just want to be
able to unlock--turn on screen and hit skip
basically for it to do its thing.
If we look in the notification--we've got
the notification there so it's here, but we
don't have the controls in
notification either which again it's a bit
painful--means I need to navigate into the
app to be able to control it.
And we also see that it hasn't actually navigated
me to--directly to the lyrics page.
But I guess there's no need,
right?
>>Adam: That's true.
It's still on the [unintelligible]
>>Reto: Anything here that lets me hit pause
is probably sufficient.
>>Adam: Right.
We also have what seems to be a bit of a legacy
FROYO style notification icon in the status
bar here
as well with the gradient frame around it.
It's a minor--
>>Reto: Yeah.
Cool.
Should we have a quick look at the playback
on the tablet as well.
I'm just curious to see
whether the experience on the tablet sort
of lives up to the phone version.
>>Adam: Yeah.
>>Ian: While you're going over to that, let
me break in for just a second.
There's a couple things--oh, there's two
of you-- the couple of things that I wanted
to bring up, first, that apparently TuneWiki
is a massively complex
program that deserves its own hour of work
because you're still talking about it half
an hour after the show has
started.
[Reto laughs]
>>Adam: It's true, we probably should move
on.
>>Ian: Most importantly though, we actually
did get a comment on the G-plus stream last
night from Rafael Szuminski
who I think has a really good question, he
asks, "if you have time, can you please go
into detail and explain the behavior of the
up
navigation versus the back button in the play
music apps, specifically how is it affected
by different entry points
into the app?"
So when you guys get a chance, as you're looking
at the action bar, I think a lot of people
would
like to have a better explanation of up versus
back.
>>Reto: And happily we have the right person
in the room because Adam gave a talk about
this very subject at Google
IO this year.
>Adam: Oh.
>>Ian: Did he invent the word 'affordance'?
>>Reto: I hope so.
>>Ian: 'Cause I'm still confused by that,
so--
>>Adam: No.
No, not at all.
>>Ian: Okay.
>>Reto: You're not willing to take blame slash
credit for 'affordance'?
No?
All right.
>>Adam: I don't think so.
So we can definitely go ahead and include
links not only to the design guide on the
topic of up versus back but also
to the talk that we gave at IO for that topic
as well.
I think that it, depending on some of the
complex cases that
you can get into, it can get somewhat sophisticated
although I think that there's a few overarching
guidelines that
tend to dominate.
>>Reto: Cool.
Well as we go through these other apps, we'll
see if there's an opportunity, because you're
absolutely
right we should move on.
>>Adam: Right, and in the interest of time
as well, I know that we were going to look
at the Tablet UI on some of
these.
>>Reto: Yes.
>>Adam: But by and large, I think that music
apps are the sort of apps that--it's used
to replace pocket MP3 players
in many cases.
>>Reto: Mmm.
>>Adam: I mean it's entirely reasonable to
really focus on the experience on a phone
for a music app, so--
>>Reto: Yeah.
>>Adam: We'll go ahead and call out when an
application did a particularly good job of
providing a tablet UI in
addition to the phone experience--
>>Reto: Absolutely.
>>Adam: But in the interest of time maybe
we should skip it for now.
>>Reto: We should move on.
Let's have a look at--actually, let's have
a look at a few of these together.
We'll check
out XenoAmp, XenoAmp, and probably XenoAmp
at the same time?
>>Adam: Okay, I think that might save some
time there.
>>Reto: I think that makes sense.
Okay, cool.
So let's switch to the phone.
We've cleared data so we can start from scratch.
All right, perfect.
>>Adam: First off, I think that we might have
a bit of a trademark issue on this.
It looks like the XenoAmp has used
the Nexus X four color iconography in its
app icon.
>>Reto: [sharp intake of breath] Mmm, yeah.
So you want to watch that so maybe choose
a different logo that doesn't
quite infringe on another trademark.
Let's fire it up.
So it's warning us that this is an early version
and we need to turn off our firewall or disable
it for XenoAmp.
[clicks tongue]
Yeah.
I don't know that that's the first thing you
want to be telling people to inspire confidence,
like you know,
"Remove security precautions so that our app
can do stuff."
I don't know that makes me a little nervous.
>>Adam: It's slightly sketchy, although they
do have a nice playful voice with this, with
their 'yeah yeah' button
instead of an 'okay'.
>>Reto: And these kind of goes throughout
the whole app which are quite nice, and so
[claps hands together] we're
going to go right off the bat and point out
that this is clearly an early version and
so we're gonna--it's definitely
something we're going to look at--but in line
with the playful attitude of the developers,
we're going to take a
similar attitude, I think, in looking at this
app and hopefully you guys will take it in
the spirit it was intended.
So, this is where we start, with authentication
failure.
'Touch me here stopped.'
So I touch here, and nothing
happens.
>>Adam: Well something's lighting up there.
>>Reto: So there is something.
>>Adam: So if we touch and hold here--okay--
>>Reto: Okay.
>>Adam: Now we've got something that starts
resembling a UI.
>>Reto: So let go so we can see what else
to press.
>>Adam: All right.
>>Reto: Nope, now it's fading away.
>>Adam: Fading away.
So the first thing that I notice--
>>Reto: Ah!
>>Adam:--with this app is not only do they
hide the status bar, but then they create
their own.
So XenoAmp has its
own clock and its title is occupying the space
where notifications would normally be, along
with what looks to be a
battery read out.
>>Reto:Yeah,and so okay, so to be clear, we
spend a lot of time, and I think I in particular
have spent a lot of time
online talking about how I hate it when apps
hide the status bar because you know I use
the status bar to see what
time it is, to see how much battery I've got
left.
The solution I was looking for was not to
just put the time and
the battery into your own fake status bar--I
was kind of just using those as examples--leave
the status bar.
Unless
you're just sort of consuming content that's
supposed to be immersive, there's really no
reason to take that away.
>>Adam: So there was one exception to that
actually.
>>Reto: Please.
>Adam: You'll notice this in a lot of apps--is
that if you go into landscape mode--landscape
mode you're very
constrained for that vertical real estate--so
a lot of times it makes sense to hide the
status bar in landscape but
still bring it back in portrait so that if
the user needs to get back to their notifications
so on and so forth, they
can simply rotate the device and get it back.
In this case, this app offers neither.
>>Reto: All right, so let's continue to touch--see,
I'm touching the wrong place 'cause I can't
get that--oop--there
we go.
So I need to drag--
>>Adam: You need to start sliding around.
>>Reto: So I need to move in order to get
things and so again, none of these is entirely
clear what I need to do to
listen to stuff.
>>Adam: Well, we could try music down at the
bottom.
>>Reto: But I guess music makes sense.
So if I drag down to music, then I get this
kind of wacky display.
Now it's
clear that whoever has put this together has
some, I'm guessing, open GL skills?
But this list view is kind of
surreal in that--
>>Adam: It's clearly not a list view just
in the way that it behaves.
It doesn't follow the same sort of fling
physics--
>>Reto: The fling physics are phenomenal,
it's almost like --just sort of accelerates.
So I start a little and
straightaway it shoots up and seems to just
want to keep going like it's in some sort
of anti-gravity well.
Which is kind of cool.
And then I can move these thing around but
it's not really clear to what purpose.
See, it was
just going off screen beforehand, but it isn't
happening now, but--
>>Adam: I think this is meant to get to different
albums within a certain artist's catalog--
but why you're able to
scroll this one when all of it would fit on
screen and there's only one album available--ehhhhh,
it's maybe
questionable.
>>Reto: You're just kind of wondering what
is the--you know, I'm touching things and
everything's moving and I'm not
really sure why and how.
Oop.
There I guess.
The Jimmy Smith is gone.
I think I can get him back--
>>Adam: Maybe not.
>>Reto: Maybe not.
So I'll have to come back.
>>Ian: You know, one thing to notice on the,
on that scrolling list view is that that actually
does look a lot like
what you'd see with our default physics, if
you don't know the magic numbers to plug in
to scale it.
>>Reto: Is that right?
>>Ian: Uh, yeah.
Yeah, if you look at the class that I wrote
on custom controls--
>>Reto: Mmm Hmm.
>>Ian: You'll actually see that I actually
had to plug in a couple magic numbers that
I pulled out of a Speed code base
to make sure that the physics scaled correctly
and didn't feel like they were too fast.
>>Adam: Really, all right.
>>Reto: So that's an Android U class you've
got at, let's see, developer@android.com/training?
And it's called
"Building Custom Views?"
>>Ian: It is called, yeah, something like
"Building Custom views," "Making Custom Views",
something like that.
>>Reto: Cool.
We'll paste that link into the G-plus stream
I think, and check that out.
>>Ian: Sounds wonderful.
>>Adam: Yeah, and in a spirit of a BETA, we
also have our FPS counter up in the corner
there that's uh---
>>Reto: That's right.
You probably can't quite see it, but that's
what this number here is.
Which is running at a
pretty decent sort of twenty-nine to thirty?
>>Adam: Thirty-ish, until you actually start
scrolling at which point--
>>Reto:No, it's still staying up around thirty.
>>Adam: It gets down--it gets down here and
there but--
>>Reto: It's not bad.
>>Adam: They're tracking performance which
is good at a phase of development like this.
>>Reto: That's good.
So let's actually navigate in and try and
play an album.
So we've got this album, and again, everything
is this nice
slide-y, scroll-y view.
It looks really cool, if a little impenetrable
in terms of navigation, because we're here
now and I'm not really clear where we are--there's
no action bar, there's no sort of obvious
navigation, I can bring
up this weird sort of slider-y thing which
is kind of like my navigation-y thing and
I can move stuff around but it's
not entirely clear what I'm doing or why these
things are moving.
>>Adam: So, if we try to drill in on this--
>>Reto: See, nothing happens.
>>Adam: Then select something.
>>Reto: So what you guys can't tell, which
we can tell is that this is actually failing
the first test--we can't
figure out how to make it play music.
Pressing this, selecting this does nothing.
There's no sort of play affordance, see I
love that word.
>>Adam: Now wait, now we have it on a list--
>>Reto: It's here on a list--
>>Adam: Have we added this to a playlist at
this point?
>>Reto: I think so, but I don't know how to
make the playlist play.
>>Ian: You just said my pet peeve, which is
playlist, you know I have nothing against
playlist per se, but
when you're required to put something on a
playlist before you freakin' play it--that's
wrong.
You shouldn't have to
set things up before you do what the app is
meant to do.
>>Reto: Absolutely.
This is--
>>Ian: We discussed this in podcast players
and went nuts on it then, this is even worse.
[laughter]
>>Reto: Absolutely.
I totally agree--it fails that fundamental
rule which is you should be able to start
doing
whatever the point of the app is with as few--
[music starts playing]
>>Adam: OH.
>>Reto: Oh you found a way!
>>Adam: We started playing music.
>>Reto: Outstanding!
How?
>>Ian: Crap!
Now The Man's gonna cut us off.
>>Adam: That's a good question.
>>Reto: We have four seconds.
>>Ian: Oh yeah.
>>Adam: We got it closed down.
[laughter]
>>Reto: How did you do this Adam?
While we, me--
>>Adam: That's a good question.
>>Reto: And Ian were talking shit you managed
to play music.
>>Adam:I'm going to assume, right.
I think the core issue about this app is really
discoverability.
>>Reto: Mmm.
>Adam: I think that they've got this really
interesting UI that they are putting together
something that is clearly
meant to be operated using fingers, using
gestures.
It seems like they might be onto something
really interesting--
>>Reto: Mm hmm.
>>Adam: But you can really end up spending
a lot of time with this app without it being
entirely obvious how to
perform basic functions that you may be familiar
with from other music apps.
>>Reto: Absolutely.
I think that's kind of the key here and so
it--and this is something which I think Ian
and
myself have spoken about particularly in--hopefully
he'll agree with me--you don't have to make
an app that looks
like every other android app.
Doesn't have to have an action bar, doesn't
have to have to have list views, like
something like what they've done here to create
something quite radically different is actually
kind of cool.
You
know, we like apps which are innovative and
change the way you expect things to happen
--
>>Adam: Right.
>>Reto: But--
>>Adam: And music apps have long been the
source of this sort of innovation--
>>Reto: Absolutely.
>>Adam:-- and a number of different operating
systems and I mean you can think back to the
early '90's where had
things that looked like car stereos on your
desktops and so on and so forth.
>>Reto: Absolutely.
It was the whole skinning community about
WinAmp which no one nominated this week so
we're not
going to look at it, but that was kind of
the whole point of WinAmp was to get all these
cool different custom
looking UI's--
>>Adam: Exactly.
>>Reto: Which is kind of cool.
>>Adam: So if there's ever a place to experiment
like this, a music or media player app is
really kind of a great
fertile ground for doing so.
>>Reto: That's true.
>>Ian: I actually feel like I could find myself
totally loving this app, like it could become
my favorite music
player.
Partly just because, I think what they're
doing, now I could be wrong, but I think what
they're doing with
the UI is making it easy to operate without
really looking at it.
You know, I'm just going to touch it in a
really
predictable place in the middle of the screen
on a target that's gigantic and then I'm just
going to slide my finger
one way or the other right?
Not right now, because it's not working, but
seemed like you might be able to.
>>Reto: Yeah, this is part of the navigation
issue that we see now.
Now that the various things come up, and so
I
guess that's really it, it's just--
>>Adam: It almost seems like perhaps we're
running into bugs at that point.
>>Reto: It could well be and I think, if that's
what you guys are trying to do, I think that's
great like and maybe
you're just suffering from that eighty-twenty
rule where it's eighty percent of the way
there, you've got all the
functionality; you've got all the navigation
but twenty percent that remains to be done
is the bit that makes it
actually impossible to navigate if you don't
know the magic things to press.
>>Ian: That's right.
>>Reto: And that's why it's really important
that you get people to BETA test your apps
and really watch to see how
they use them.
Because I'm sure if the developer for this
app were standing behind us, he'd be like.
"No, no, no.
You just have to press here and then here.
Why are you pressing over there?
Why are you dragging that?
Why are you
pressing the back button?"
>>Adam: BETA testing is really an illuminating
experience.
>>Reto: It really is.
>>Adam: When you're sitting behind a glass
where they can't see you [Reto laughs], you
just want to jump through
and--
>>Reto: Pound on the glass, "Why?!?!?"
Yeah, and this is why testers are really valuable.
Us engineering folks, we have this tendency
to know how it works
and then do it the right way.
And then you put it in front of testers and
they're like trying to press two buttons at
the same time.
"Why are you pressing okay and cancel at the
same time?
Why are you pressing okay like ten times in
a
row real quick?"
All these little bits and pieces when you
see people actually using your app, or testing
them,
trying to break them, is how you really get
that next stage polish to something which
people really love and are
excited about.
>>Adam: That's right.
So this app doesn't claim to be more than
a BETA at this point and I think that at this
point,
it's good.
>>Reto:[Absolutely] I think at this point
it's really more of an Alpha just given that
it's just a little too hard to
use.
It's a little too frustrating.
I want to see you guys spend a little more
time building something that's just a
little bit more predictable before you spend
too much more effort getting it out there.
>>Adam: Or at least start guiding the user
through the first time--that always makes
it a little more--
>>Reto: Absolutely.
All right, let's move on to the next app.
Now, none of us have a Spotify account set
up right now.
>>Adam: Yeah, we tested this on some other
devices previously.
>>Reto: Yeah.
Spotify in general, given that we're running
out of time a little bit here, I think it's
probably a
reasonable one to skip.
It's a great app, fantastic functionality
and a pretty decent UI.
And they've actually worked
pretty well in terms of getting some of the
newest features integrated.
Things like widgets and universal search
they were building those sorts of things straight
off the bat so so check out Spotify it's pretty
cool, but we're
going to skip past that one.
>>Adam: One of the other things that we were
going to highlight in Spotify as well is that
they do use the ever
emerging pattern of the side drawer that slides
out from one side so I believe that the most
recent update to the
Android design guide has a few words to say
about that as well so--
>>Reto: Yes.
It does.
>>Adam: Definitely go check that out if you're
interested.
>>Reto: That's the big tip.
Yeah, so definitely go check that out if you're
interested in the drawer pattern, do
check out the new design site update.
It has a whole section on that.
The "too long didn't read" version, the way
YouTube does it, is pretty much spot on.
So if you do want to know what is the right
way to implement that, that’s
probably the right place to start.
>>Adam: That's right.
>>Reto: Let’s look at UberHype.
[pause]
>>Adam: Powered by the hype machine.
>>Reto: There's a lot of hype going on here.
So you know again, this passes the test of
straightaway--you start up
the app, you have a list of music, you press
a music track--
>>Adam: And it actually does start playing--
>>Reto: It starts playing music.
Which is perfect.
It’s exactly what you want from an app--from
a music playing app.
We go to the home screen, we can go down here,
I think that's, yeah, that's it's--
>>Adam: You can go back.
It has back navigation.
>>Reto: We can navigate here.
Unfortunately, there's no ability to control
the playback from the notifications, which
is a bit of a disappointment.
>>Adam: How 'bout the lock screen?
>>Reto: Let's try the lock screen.
Let's try the lock screen again.
>>Adam: Oh, there we go.
>>Reto: It does.
How nice.
So they have the lock screen integrate--
>>Adam: Hold on wait a second.
Was this the same song we were--
>>Reto: Wait.
>>Adam:--no I believe this was from one of
our earlier apps.
I think that we still have the--is that XenoAmp
or one
of the other ones?
>>Reto: Could be one of the other ones which
is already running.
>>Adam: Let's go ahead and clear these out
just to
[Reto laughs]
make sure that we're set here.
>>Reto: Yeah.
So let's go back to UberHype.
>>Adam: We still have an indication sitting
up there in that corner.
[pause]
>>Reto: Hmm.
>>Adam: Interesting.
[Reto laughs]
All right we may need to be a little more
aggressive for that one.
>>Reto: All right.
So that's another app that's behaving a little
less politely.
>>Adam: Yeah.
>>Reto: Yeah, so the music is there but unfortunately
not on the lock screen but it does mean that
they are probably not using the audio focus
quite correctly because that should clear
out any other app that's
playing.
>>Adam: That's right.
Let's just go ahead and kill this too to be
sure here--
>>Reto: What's confusing is it's what's playing
on the tablet.
>>Adam: Ah, yeah that's true.
[Reto laughs]
>>Reto: Yeah it was XenoAmp.
So that works anyway on having the lock screen
controls.
>>Adam: [unintelligible] Okay.
[pause]
So testing once again.
We don't, in fact, have lock screen controls.
>>Reto: Boo.
Oh, I was so hopeful.
>>Adam: Oh wait.
Does it happen when we're playing perhaps?
>>Reto: Maybe that helps.
Let's have a look.
No.
>>Adam: Nope.
We still have nothin'.
[Reto laughs]
>>Reto: Okay, so that's fine.
You can heart things here, which is nice.
Well, theoretically.
>>Adam: Oh.
>>Reto: So you need to be a member of the
HypeMachine for that.
>>Adam: HypeMachine.
>>Reto: And actually this is a pattern that
I actually quite like.
Nothing gets hidden, nothing gets removed.
If you
try and do something that requires a membership,
then you point it out and give people the
opportunity to join.
>>Adam: Right.
You wait until the last minute to require
that log in so that people can really make
that informed
decision whether or not they take that step
and want to create an account for your service.
>>Reto: Exactly.
>>Ian: I am going to make one--I've got one
thing to say about that heart button.
Shouldn't that be a star button?
>>Reto: Well, you know, it probably should,
but I guess it kind of depends on what they
mean by it, by the heart
button.
>>Ian: Right.
>>Reto: If they're favoriting something for
their own sake, I think that star is a much
better metaphor, but if they
are favoriting it, as in promoting it to their
friends as something which they are enjoying,
the heart--it kind of almost
makes more sense.
>>Ian: Hmm.
By the way, I noticed that when we're doing
this top to bottom thing, it totally doesn't
work to have us looking left
to right.
I think what we--yeah--what we want is to
be like this-- like 'Brady Bunch' style.
>>Reto: What do you see?
>>Ian: Hey Reto, how's it going?
>>Reto: This is weird.
>>Adam: Hey.
>>Ian: Nice.
LOVE it!
[laughter]
Yeah, I'm just saying that you don't get to
pick your favorite, you know, 'Lucky Charms'
metaphor.
There's a star
[Reto laughs]
for making something your favorite and the
heart means kind of nothing to the average
Android user.
>>Reto: That's true.
>>Ian: So, something to think about.
>>Adam: Well, for something that ties into
an existing service, if you already have a
metaphor for doing--performing
an action like this--then sometimes it makes
sense to stay consistent with the rest of
that service as well.
>>Ian: That is a really good point, yeah.
>>Reto: So we see that in this screen, we
actually have the menu button of shame.
It's there, it does nothing.
Which
is particularly weird because we've got this
action bar type metaphor.
While we're here, we'll also see what happens
when we hit the share button--we get the sharing
apps which is nice.
>>Adam: [unintelligible].
>>Reto: So that's happy making.
Now what's a little bit weirder is this icon
here which I have no idea what that
means--a sort of filter?
>>Adam: So great.
>>Reto: It's an overflow button, right?
>>Adam: It's almost an overflow located in
the opposite position that you normally would
expect an overflow button to
be.
>>Reto: So it's kind of a right to left overflow,
and now it's weird, because if we've got an
overflow then we don't
need the menu button along the bottom.
And if we go back--
>>Adam: This is another example of a non-standard
action bar as well.
>>Reto: Absolutely.
>>Adam: It's using just a little bit different
size for everything.
Little bit different metrics, and it stands
out.
>>Reto: And if we go back to the main menu--we
find out that here, the menu button isn't
a button of shame, but it is
confusing because everything in this is just
as appropriate when you're listening to a
track as when you're looking
at list of tracks.
>>Adam: And we do have one of your favorite
actions--[unintelligible]
>>Reto: Exit button.
Yay!
NO!
There's no need for an exit button.
For a music playing app, as soon as you are
paused, that should be the equivalent of everything
stopping, there shouldn't be any services
running, there
shouldn't be any difference at that point
between hitting exit or just hitting back.
That should be equivalent, so
then there's no need to put it in there because,
again, as soon as you have an exit button--I
understand that some
users like an exit button and it's a nice
thing to put in there but it's totally ambiguous.
It's meaningless.
You don't--no one actually knows what that
exit button is going to do--so putting it
there just runs the risk of
frustrating your users and annoying the hell
out of me.
Let's go back in here.
>>Adam: Yeah.
>>Reto: Splash screen every time we start
up again--is that really necessary?
Like, you know, reticulating splines
here.
You should just be able to start off and have
these things cached so that we get a nice
clean quick startup
every time.
>>Adam: Although I do have to say that if
you are loading something for the very first
time, showing something a
little more attractive than a loading spinner
I think that that gets points.
>>Reto: Yeah, I think so.
I think the first time you load, you want
to have something and we have sort of preferences
around how much time you should be showing
a blank screen, i.e. no time.
So definitely having a splash screen or
loading screen the first time is nice, but
everything after the first time, I feel like
you should already have that
data cached in a way that you can bring stuff
up quickly.
>>Adam: And just to run through a couple of
other things very quickly before we move on--you'll
notice that we do
have the top tabs here to move between some
different elements, but we don't actually
have the ability to swipe
between these--we do have sort of a long press
action, presented in a nicer way than your
standard pop up dialog.
>>Reto: Yeah, that's reasonable.
>>Adam: So as you flip between here, we do
get a short period of loading before we bring
it up.
>>Reto: Yeah.
A bit of pre-caching would be nice as well.
There's a good chance that you're going to
hit these top
actions so after you've loaded the first one
and nothing else is happening, just pre-load
them in the background.
>>Adam: Sounds good.
>>Reto: And it would be relatively cheap.
>>Adam: And if this was something that sits
in a view pager then suddenly the loader's
attached to different fragments
make that very easy to implement so on and
so forth.
>>Reto: Absolutely.
Let's--
>>Adam: The other thing that sort of kind
of shows as well, is we have this bottom strip
on each one of these pages
as well.
It's kind of like a second set of tabs, kind
of not.
Is it more of a filter?
Is it from different sources?
We can go for Twitter over here as well--
so this is something that always sort of bothers
me in apps, when you try to
sandwich different levels of hierarchy on
opposite sides of the content.
I think it makes it more difficult to tell
where you're drilling down into that hierarchy
so on and so forth.
>>Reto: Hmm.
>>Adam: And in this app in particular, you
have a very small touch target for these bottom
tabs that sits right next
to the capacitive buttons for navigation,
even on devices that don't use the soft navigation.
>>Reto: Hmm.
A couple of other points really quickly before
we jump on the lightning round for the last
two apps in
two minutes.
We're using a non-standard font here?
And Roman's not here, so he can't go on at
length about
typography.
It's a nice font.
But it is a little disconcerting maybe?
Just having that different that font style
here, I don't know that it entirely works,
but--
>>Adam: It looks like it might be part of
their brand for the rest of the service they
hold so--
>>Reto: That could well be, that could well
be.
>>Adam: So we'd have to dig a little bit deeper
into that.
>> Reto: And the very last thing I want to
say is that what's not clear to me as a music
listener is where this music
is coming from and what the rights are for
them.
So it seems like someone is blogging about
them, you know, I'm very
conscious of not wanting to pirate music when
there's plenty of sources that I can use to
get it for free.
I have
absolutely no idea what the scenario is here,
but that's kind of the point is it would be
nice to have some better
idea exactly how this music is coming to be
on my phone.
>>Adam: Or how it's going to be available
to me if I get on an airplane?
>>Reto: Exactly.
All right, so lightening round, we've got
Poweramp and PlayerPro, which both have very
similar icon stylings and as
it turns out fairly similar functionality.
So let's start with Poweramp real quick.
>>Adam: So Poweramp's been a longtime favorite
of a lot of others around the office here.
>>Reto: Hmm.
>>Adam: And once you start getting into it,
it becomes really easy to see why.
So they seem to stick with a lot of
Android conventions just keep you familiar
with basic functionality.
You've got not quite in action bar but very
similar here.
Metrics are a little bit off-- It looks like
it may actually be in action bar [thumping
and pouring
sounds] with some other modifications to it--we'd
have to look a little bit closer to be certain.
>>Reto: Hmm.
>>Adam: But the convention is there.
See you know where to look for the sort of
thing.
>>Reto: Exactly.
And as soon as you start pressing on the screen
it shows that these are bars and things that
you
can press and you get the little help texts
and things as well.
>>Adam: Absolutely.
>>Reto: Which is really nice.
>>Adam: So this is a great feature as well--is
this ability to just swipe between tracks
that you have available.
>>Reto: So this totally makes my 'in the car'
experience work in that if I want to skip
the track, is just a swipe.
I don't need to look at it or find the fast
forward key.
I just swipe in the middle of the screen.
>>Adam: Right.
>>Reto: If we hit play--I can't change the
volume which is nice--we actually find out
here, we can see that it does
have controls in the notification.
Which is excellent.
And I don't know if it has it in the lock
screen.
Unfortunately it doesn't have it in the lock
>>Adam: No, this is the one where we had slightly
different options.
>>Reto: Oh, right.
>>Ian: User Jimjam mentions that you actually
do need to enable the lock screen controls
in the settings.
>>Reto: We did in fact discover that, or at
least Adam did.
>>Adam: Right, this is the sort of thing it
would be really great if the app would detect
which sort of platform it
was running on and just automatically enable
this on default.
But the fact that it is there it still gets
points.
>>Reto: Exactly so that's great but it doesn't
seem like there's a good reason not to have
that as a default action.
I'd actually be quite curious to know from
the developers' perspective why that is.
You know why not default it on
given that you can detect what version of
Android you're running on.
>>Adam: Yeah, it seems to be that they had
some other functionality to enable controls
on the lock screen in previous
versions of the platform as well so it may
have been a matter of trying to keep your
settings as migrated so as not
to lose users through in OS upgrade.
>>Reto: That makes sense.
So maybe it's just a simple case of checking
to see whether it's an upgrade or not in
default in your options that way.
>>Adam: That's true.
>>Reto: We had some really nice options here,
we're not going to go in too much depth but
really pretty controls for
the equalizer.
In fact, you know, base, treble, volume, the
whole the whole thing.
In fact if you go back--oh it
doesn't--maybe it's just in landscape version--it
has this nice effect.
At least I thought that it did of showing
the equalizer in the action bar.
I can't get that to come up right now.
>>Adam: Oh I think that was if you run it
on a tablet.
>>Reto: Maybe that was [unintelligible].
>>Adam: This is one of the apps that provides
some interesting functionality on a tablet
as well.
>>Reto: Cool.
So we are totally out of time so we're not
going to into any more detail here.
But generally speaking
this is a really nice app.
Great functionality, does pretty much everything
that we ask it to in terms of what a
music player should do.
So yeah, nicely done.
>>Adam: Most of all, I really want to pull
this out as well, PowerAmp, and TuneWiki on
its list of songs as well,
you can really tell that they spent time optimizing
and made sure that the entire experience was
very smooth.
>>Reto: Absolutely.
They're really polished, really nicely done.
Now I know that our engineer is going to--
>>Adam: Get nervous.
>>Reto: He's going to get really nervous if
we don't wrap up soon 'cause we're not going
to have any time for the
team at The Friday Game Review to get started
so we're going to put a hold on PlayerPro
and see if we can't get a
chance to look at that at another point.
Absolutely so far, we're really happy with
most of the apps we looked at
today.
I think that there's some really polished
experiences and some interesting up and comers
so definitely some
interesting perspectives on the genre.
>>Adam: And what was really great was all
these apps really took a different approach
to playing music, I mean, you
don't see a lot of clone functionality between
these apps.
>>Reto: Very true.
And we didn't even have to go and pick and
choose different things that was just by virtue
of what
was on front page at moderator.
Speaking of which, next week we're going to
be looking at football apps in celebration
of the beginning of the NFL
season here in the U.S. so if you have a football
app of any kind, please do nominate it in
the moderator so the team
can check it out next week.
We're also going to try and start integrating
interviews with some of the developers of
some of these apps probably a week afterwards,
so anyone who been reviewed on The Friday
App Clinic or The Friday
Review which came before hand, do drop us
a line if you're interesting in talking through
some of your decisions or
in fact if you've made any changes that you'd
like to share with us all.
And we'll see if we can get you on a Hangout
in one of the next few weeks to talk it over.
In the meantime, thank you guys very much
for tuning in and thank you, Adam, for joining
us this week.
>>Adam: You're welcome.
>>Reto: Thank you Ian for producing the show.
>>Ian: You're welcome and don't forget to
stick around for the brand new Friday Game
Review starring Dan Galpin and
new co-host, Koh Kim.
>>Reto: Outstanding.
That should be a good one, and thank you to
Daniel for engineering as always, and we'll
see you
guys all next week.